so listen I've said before when it comes  to Thanksgiving I will take two or three  beautifully roasted chickens over a  massive turkey any day I'm not a purist  when it comes to Thanksgiving because  I'm not even from the United States and  I think that chicken is more Savory you  can cook it in an hour I would go with  the chicken over the turkey but I've had  okay turkey and I know good turkey when  I see it and Marjorie Taylor green  posted a picture of herself with a  Thanksgiving turkey that looks  absolutely vile and disgusting I've  never seen such a disgusting looking  looking dirty first of all there seems  to be no seasoning whatsoever on it I  mean just zero seasoning  and it just doesn't look right it  doesn't look healthy  in her defense Marjorie Taylor green  never claimed to be good at cooking she  claims to be good at things she's also  terrible at but she never claimed to be  good at cooking